Jason what's your advice to directors on
directing actors well my my advice for
directors on directing actors you know
the III was find that less is more and I
find the more direct directors can be
when they're talking to actor is the
better certainly you know I've been on
both sides of that equation obviously
I'm an actor as well so I and I find
that I find that the more the more
delicate a director tries to be the more
frustrating it is for for everyone
involved I find the more direct you can
be and the less you can say the better
the better you are the better the better
it is for everybody interesting so
you're not sort of tiptoeing around
trying to know just somebody to be
direct and concise you know I I find me
as a director and me and maybe it's
because I you know I'm so you know I I
understand the secret language of actors
because I'm one as well but I can go up
and just say one word to an actor and
and I know go
Oh got it okay good and and that's it
like the less you can say the better
you